[inaudible] joining me today is the host of Tucker Carlson tonight on Fox News,
now a New York Times bestselling author with his new book ship of fools,
Tucker Carlson.
Welcome to the Rubin.
I am glad to have you here,
my friend.
I'm glad to be here.
I love this.
I don't know that anyone has ever walked in here and been more impressed by the
Rubens and television,
so I know what this is and it's just the coolest thing I've seen in a long time.
Are you jealous?
Are you joking?
Yes,
I'm jealous.
You have millions and millions of viewers driving across a massive staff,
but I don't have the control that you have,
which is wonderful.
Yeah,
control.
All right,
so speaking of control,
I have only one goal for the next hour,
which is to some point say something so ludicrous that you stare at me with that
face.
We are where I can make do that.
Where did the face come?
It's totally everyone that memes that come into that layer.
Yannick.
Well,
the funny thing is when,
I mean that's just my face at rest,
which is golden retriever.
Like I'm a mouth breather.
And when I first started this show,
um,
I got complaints about it internally and the idea was it's too embarrassing.
Click more on.
Um,
but I can't stop,
I can't help myself.
So I'm not as super self aware person.
I'm not a mirror user for example,
because if you work in TV and you become really self conscious,
it destroys you and makes you insecure.
So I just am trained after 20 years not to think about the way I look.
And I didn't even know that I look like a moron listening,
but I do and I'm not changing.
Well I know you're not be asking because even just now when you were in the
green room and my girl is putting makeup on your you,
you sat there for literally two seconds,
you were like,
don't do anything.
You didn't even look at the mirror.
You are looking at me and you can go crazy.
As you know in TV,
if you start to think about how other people perceive you,
you just drown in Lake me,
you know?
And I don't want that.
All right.
So I'm glad to have you here for a couple of reasons.
We're going to get into the book and obviously we're kind of simpatico and what
I think are the big issues of the day to free speech and all that stuff.
But I will be totally honest with you,
years ago when I first saw you on a crossfire on CNN and I was not a fan now,
I was now,
I was living alone in that.
I thought,
here's this bow tie wearing guide who's seemingly kind of smug and whatever.
And I was a lefty at the time,
so,
so we were really polar opposites politically,
but everything has shifted enough that that we are kind of allies now.
And I actually think that's kind of cool.
So before we do anything else,
tell me about little Tucker Carlson.
People know about Tucker Carlson that eviscerates socialists all day.
What was that like as a kid?
Yeah,
in southern California and um,
we lived in studio city and I mean,
I think I've always been the same anti-authoritarian for the individual against
the group.
Um,
I hate bullies.
I hate being bullied more than anything.
And so if I find myself,
and I've always been this way in a scenario where everyone is forced to sort of
nod in bovine agreement about something,
my instinct is always to be the one guy who was like,
no.
And um,
so I,
I haven't changed at all.
The particulars of my political beliefs have changed because America has changed
so dramatically.
I'm 49,
so in the last 40 years it's become a different country and a lot of the things
that I thought would work haven't worked.
A lot of the things I thought were not threatening turned out to be threatening.
So,
you know,
my views have changed,
but my instincts have remained I think consistent over time.
Were you always political or were your parents I was always political.
Well I was always interested in history and my father was a non conformist,
I would say.
I mean that's an understatement.
And his baseline position was just because everybody says it doesn't mean it's
true and the answers to the way,
uh,
people are found in history because the one immutable fact of history as human
nature,
like it literally does not change.
And you see consistent themes over time.
And so if you want to understand what's happening,
look backward and you will,
I mean,
just pretty conventional stuff.
But now it sounds kind of radical,
but,
um,
basically at my main influence was my dad.
I grew up with my dad and my brother.
And again,
his view was,
you know,
just because all the Chin tuggers are saying it does not prove it.
Yeah.
Does that seem like a pretty obvious through line to your success right now?
Because it's like every day there is some other group think exactly lunacy that
it's like these people then go onto your show.
And I always think it's hilarious because it's like,
do they know what they're getting into?
Do Your,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
because I think they're going to be a,
and we'll,
but they don't actually have the same goals for the debate that I do.
So I'm linear and literal and old fashioned and I go into it,
you know,
believing that I can win the person over,
um,
with superior reasoning or larger and more compelling fact set or whatever.
They're coming to this believing they've already won because they have superior
virtue.
So they're having a theological conversation.
I'm having a political debate and too often we talk rate the past,
each of that's interesting theological conversation.
A couple,
a couple of people have mentioned on the show,
my friend Peter,
because he was a philosophy professor who's been on a few times,
he calls this sort of new leftism a secular religion.
Of course.
Do you view that,
look,
I'm going to Pisco Paleon so I know what happened because the episcopal church
was the church of them,
of America's ruling class,
our national cathedral,
an episcopal church.
So our culture was rooted in mainline Protestantism.
I mean this was a Protestant country and our rulers,
whether they were like literally Protestant or not internalized the values of
that faith.
And then within like a 20 year period,
the faith of apparated,
the episcopal church barely exists anymore.
And certainly as a national force,
it's irrelevant,
but that didn't eliminate the religious impulse within people,
which is inherent.
It's innate.
We're born that way.
We worship something in the end,
whether,
you know,
it doesn't need to be God.
Um,
and so they've transferred that religious impulse to the political sphere.
They're making the same arguments that 19th century Protestants made,
especially the Calvinists.
Like,
I am saved.
Like I know this.
That's my baseline assumption.
I'm one of God's elect.
You were not,
if you go into any conversation like that,
nothing will be resolved because,
because it's already been decided.
Well it's,
it's good versus evil.
Exactly.
Why exactly what it is.
Yeah.
Was it always like this?
No,
it wasn't like what,
what gimme gimme some markers of when you saw things kind of start to change.
I mean,
I've kind of,
you know,
I'm not an intellectual and a talk show host,
so I'm a little,
now we have our promo clip.
Well,
it's,
it's true.
I mean that's what I do.
Um,
so it took me a while to see the outline.
I mean,
this all comes kind of slowly to me because I'm caught in an earlier time just
by virtue of my age.
And so I would have these conversations that were confusing to me where you
would be debating as so called liberal and I would be,
and I would find myself taking the liberal side,
like in favor of free speech or you might default suspicion of corporate power
or concentrations of power anywhere because it's a threat to the individual or
in favor of due process.
Or you know,
I would take a position that I heard liberals of my childhood take and the
liberal,
I'm debating and be like,
nope.
You know,
if Google says it,
it's true.
Or you know,
if you're accused,
prove yourself innocent or if what you say is offensive,
you don't have right to say it and be like,
wait a second,
this is a mirror image of what I grew up with.
So actually to answer your question as honestly as I can,
I don't know if they ever really meant what they said.
I really don't.
It's possible that the pursuit of power and the empowerment of the Democratic
Party was always the goal and that was just the disguise they used in order to
achieve it in 1979 I don't know the answer.
Do you think we'd be in a healthier situation if there was a same democratic
party even if all the policies were against everything that yes and believes,
yeah,
that's the point of my book.
The Fung Shui is off,
so for like a hundred years you had one party,
which was the corporate party,
the Republican Party,
the country club party,
the party of the ruling class and the other party existed in effect to keep it
in check and to say,
wait a second,
you know you're getting rich because all these people are working really hard.
You need to think about their interests and a bunch of different things happen.
The value of labor dropped because of technology to the point where it's not
even worth representing the working class because they're not worth anything
actually that this was the calculation of the Democratic Party.
And so basically what you have is this weird alignment where the leadership of
the Republican Party represents corporate interests and leadership of the
Democratic Party represents corporate interests and there's no one to represent
the middle class and that again,
the balance is off.
You need a vigorous party standing up and saying,
Whoa,
wait a second.
You need balance always.
You need balance.
Yeah.
So is that the part of this that sort of scary for our future and that's kind of
what you're going for in the book is that if one side completely implodes,
which it seems more likely as we're taping this at the moment,
that the Democrats are going to absolutely implode.
That it's not as if all the conservative policies that you might like,
we'd suddenly take root.
It's that we would actually tilt in some really bizarre,
exactly.
That's exactly right.
I mean this is why marriage is an institution works because there's like another
person pushing back against your bad instincts are balancing you out.
You know,
and what's true at home is probably true on a national scale,
on a political scale.
And yes,
you absolutely need a vigorous and principled opposition party always or else
you've got something really ugly.
Then you've got the Mana party,
which is kind of what we have.
You know Jordan Peterson,
who I know you admire also one of the lines when he's talking about politics,
it's interesting you brought up marriage.
Hello.
He say,
you know it's like a fight with your spouse.
You don't want to beat them because then you're married to a loser.
You want to give them a chance to figure out something so that you'll be able to
move forward.
We seem at this,
we're at this odd place right now where it's like one side is trying to be the
other side.
The other side I was trying to beat the other side and the rest of us,
which I think is actually most of us are just like,
that's true.
You don't want to beat your spouse because you're married to a loser,
but you're also a loser if you're married to a loser.
The point is you're implicated in the future of the other side because in the
end you're all in this together.
Even though you're coming from it from different perspectives.
So you're,
we're all Americans.
So in the same way that crushing your spouse doesn't actually win you any kind
of meaningful victory or victory you'd want crushing your fellow Americans,
doesn't improve your life or your country.
So like,
you know,
you don't want any of this.
I totally,
it's going to lead to something really bad action,
really ugly.
And everybody who's paying any kind of attention senses it on an animal level.
This is,
this is moving in a,
in a really ominous direction.
So I know we could talk about why we're frustrated with the Democrats all year
long and all that.
But let's,
let's put that aside because I feel like that's a little bit of low hanging
fruit and we both did.
We do it enough months.
So let's,
let's talk more about the Republican's.
Yes.
So tell me some of your frustrations with the Republican Party.
It's really simple.
The Democratic Party was for,
you know,
80,
probably close to a hundred years,
the party of wage earners.
And sometime in the last,
I would say 15 years,
probably at the end of the Clinton right to kind of apex of the tech boom in the
late nineties,
uh,
the Clinton ministration decided to reorient the party away from its traditional
base to it's new base,
which is the rich and the poor.
And the Republican Party being dumb didn't see this.
And it was only the emergence of Trump that forced them to sort of realize that,
wait a second,
you know,
we don't represent the people we thought we represented actually the country.
It was the country club party.
They denied it.
The hated that,
that line because it was true.
I mean it's,
it's the things that are true that we be here,
we hate the most,
but um,
we now need to become the middleclass party.
Well,
they just didn't want to become the middleclass party actually at all.
And it took Trump,
I mean,
Trump is a flawed person,
complex.
Well,
not a complex person,
but if fraud person,
we'll get to that piece of it.
But he basically has forced the Republican party to be what it in effect already
is the party of last resort for people making,
you know,
50 to $150,000 a year.
You know,
the people who are making enough not to be on welfare but not enough to send
their kids to summer camp.
That is a,
I mean that's the core of the country and they don't want to represent those
people and to,
so to me and way I'm not one of those people.
I'm not here to give you the view from coal country at all.
I grew up in La Jolla and Georgetown,
so like,
but I know less about what the middle class thinks.
I know a lot about what the ruling class things,
having lived in it my whole life and they hate the leadership of the Republican
Party,
hates the American middleclass and has contempt for them and that's infuriating.
What does it say though,
that Trump who's not one of them exactly.
To care about them?
You who's not.
One of them seems to carry them.
Me Grew up in,
I've only lived in New York and La.
Exactly.
Care about them.
Like what is that?
Why?
Why has there been such a shift that that almost seems impossible?
Well,
I mean that Trump would be the hero of these people,
but that's exactly the last time we had something like this.
Of course,
it was in the progressive era.
Teddy Roosevelt,
really the pivotal president of post civil war America,
I would argue,
who made this a capitalist country by restraining capitalism.
The,
you know,
the Romanovs didn't do that and they got 70 years bolshevism right.
But Roosevelt,
who really was a genius was like,
wait a second.
The concentrations of corporate power,
so scary.
They're gonna overwhelm the democracy and we're going to have a counter
reaction.
You don't,
the wobblies are going to take power.
So Roosevelt was the last person to fill this role and he was exactly the same,
similar to Trump.
He wasn't throwing chairs through the window into the country club.
He was throwing them out onto the street like he was from the class that he was
trying to restrain.
And you sort of have to be like,
he knew what they were like cause he was one of them.
I don't know,
there's something that,
but I would just say my,
for me it always goes back to,
I have greater sympathy for the lone guy who's getting pushed around that I do
for the group that's pushing them around.
So I feel like right now the least popular group in America,
you know,
lives in the middle west and they have kind of antiquated social attitudes and
they have very little economic power and they're overweight and everyone hates
them.
And I feel like really,
cause they're Americans actually like you don't,
what is this?
Why don't we,
if they were doing this to black people or Hispanics or any group,
I would be sympathetic because I hate that.
Yeah.
And I'm actually not even sure that when it comes to some of the social stuff
that their abuser,
that antiquated gray,
I think they've changed it.
And I think,
I mean,
I can see this from you would know,
you would know you people don't,
they want you to live however are they don't want you to come on their property
and take their stuff and you can't punch him walking down.
You're like,
damn,
the liberal gay guy from New York.
And they're like,
we love it.
Yeah,
no,
I mean,
I totally agree actually.
Yeah.
But in the mind,
in the kind of,
you know,
cliche,
controlled mind,
if your average Brooklyn intellectual,
you know,
they're all,
medieval,
but they're not actually there.
They're basically libertarian and temperament.
They always have been.
Yeah.
So what is Trump then?
You've interviewed the guy a bunch of times.
I'm,
well,
what actually in the scheme of what your book is about and sort of where America
is at at the moment,
is he just the great record that we sort of needed so that this ship of fools
wasn't gonna sink and take everybody,
he's certainly a record.
Look,
here's what Trump is not.
Trump is not the guy who comes to Washington and transforms the system because
he's not capable of that.
He's not interested in that.
Washington is a very specific town.
Okay.
So like the legislative process is highly complex.
He doesn't understand.
It.
Doesn't seek to,
he's not going to be the guy who runs on these nine policies and then affects
them once elected,
gets them to the congress,
gets them to the agents.
He's,
he can,
um,
that's not his role.
It's very frustrating actually.
If you're from DC like me to watch it,
you're like,
wow,
we don't want a second.
Get the Energy Department under control.
Not going to happen.
There's 3 million executive branch employees versus Trump Trump's role.
Is that right?
That's that right there.
There's 3 billion million,
3 million executive.
I think there are 3 million executive branch in play that at that may include
the military by the way,
which was not white.
Um,
right.
But I'm just saying like the permanent class in DC and I live right in the
center of them.
You know,
they hate Trump.
He's a threat to them.
But why do they hate him?
They hate him.
Not because he's a right winger.
He's hardly a right winger.
Actually.
He,
they hate him because he's the guy who says the obvious things.
So like w w we went to Helsinki last summer and interviewed him during the Putin
thing and I'll net like the,
this crystallized for me in this conversation I had with him off camera.
I said to,
I said something,
I'm gonna ask you about NATO.
And he goes,
why don't we have NATO?
And as someone who's looked like a Cold War Kid,
I was like,
well,
I like NATO.
I'm thinking to myself.
And he goes,
you're not the Soviet Union,
you know,
fell in 1991 it wasn't the point of Vedo keep them from invading western Europe,
but they don't exist anymore.
Why?
Why do we still have them?
And I'm trying to searching for a good answer and I couldn't find one.
So Trump repeats this in public and everyone's like,
well,
shut up.
You know,
what are you working for Putin?
And I thought,
this is what Trump does.
He comes in and his kind of autistic way and ask the obvious question at the
core of whatever the issue is.
That is the one question everyone's been avoiding because they don't have the
answer to it.
Yeah.
So like,
Whoa,
why do,
why are we sending a trade agreement and letting the other signatories ignore
the terms?
I don't,
why don't we have a border?
I don't know.
These are like not complex questions are very obvious questions,
but because they are unanswered and unanswerable,
in some cases they expose sort of the mediocrity of our ruling classic.
They actually don't know what they're doing is the truth.
All right.
So I have a lot of friends.
I think,
you know,
some of them who think that this thing that you're talking about with Trump is
this sort of existential threat to the system that this erotic miss,
this idea of you just throw the idea out there,
right.
And then let it sort of ruminate and see what happens.
That that is just too dangerous to play ball with.
I suspect you disagreed.
Well,
I don't know.
I mean I don't think you want,
I mean populism is a threat to everything that we have.
I'm not a populist,
um,
at all.
And I think it's,
but I think populism arises as a symptom of discontent that you need to address
in a democracy if you want to continue the democracy.
So,
um,
I don't want to live in a country this volatile anymore.
Nobody does.
But I think in order to solve the problems,
you have to name them.
You know,
I,
I'm not one of these guys who's like,
I believe in creative destruction is very easy to destroy things.
Very hard to build them.
Yeah.
You know,
it's incremental effort over time that builds things.
So,
no,
I mean,
look,
I understand the complaint 100%,
but I also think it's a two way deal here.
So if I say,
hey Dave,
you know,
like,
did you pay for this house?
And you're like,
that's the one thing I don't want to talk about because actually you didn't,
you're just squatting here.
Yeah.
Who's fault is that?
I mean,
I guess,
you know,
I'm disruptive for asking you the question,
but she also should pay for the house.
You delay.
Do you know what I mean?
So like he's calling bs on them.
I get why they don't like it,
but it also is a call to action to them to like answer the question in rural in
a way that is sensible and wise and sustainable and they're not.
So the byline on the
book,
how is selfish ruling classes bringing America to the brink of revolution?
Yes.
Do you think we're that close?
I think we're in the middle of it.
Yeah.
We just like to Donald Trump president.
What?
I mean,
this is like,
this is what got me to write the book.
Like Donald Trump,
who I've known for 20 years and always sort of liked because we're like,
why wouldn't you?
I think it's just funny as hell.
Did you,
did you ever do
I think he was racist or any of any of those phrases like put aside
Twitter part,
Tom?
I mean look,
I think on some level everybody is bigoted.
I mean that's,
the human heart is dark and a white and you know,
it's a patchwork.
But like talk about,
I mean,
look,
if he has a policy,
if he were to get up and say,
you know,
the problem is that this one racial group is screwing everybody else and in
response we need to crush that.
We need to attack them in public and then make it much harder for them to get
jobs.
Government contracts get into school.
That would be race saturated.
Yeah.
Oh wait.
That's what our ruling class has been doing for 35 years.
So,
right.
You want really want to have a conversation about racism.
Racism is attacking people on the basis of their immutable characteristics,
which is like how our government operates.
It's totally wrong.
Um,
so yes,
there's a lot of racism is Trump and offender.
I'd probably who isn't,
but the actual structural racism that hurts people and rewards others on the
basis of their color or something I thought we got rid of 50 years ago,
that is not being perpetuated by Trump.
It's being perpetuated and defended and celebrated by his critics.
Don't lecture me or anyone else about racism if you're pushing that crap.
Isn't that the irony?
It's a blame of half the guests that you have on your show are the people who
are actually trying to inject racism into the system.
Quotas in the rest of of course.
And then you know,
why are they doing this?
It was complicated psychological phenomenon,
but at root it's much easier to maintain power when you divide your opponents,
when you divide the country into warring tribes based on characteristics that
don't change and therefore can't be resolved.
You know,
this is how the British ruled India.
This is the problem with Rwanda.
I mean this is like a very well known phenomenon.
But anyway,
yes,
it's all projection and displacement.
It's like whatever I'm doing,
I'm accusing you of doing like I can't believe you know,
whatever it is and it's in it.
It's actually Orwellian cause it's not a lie.
It's the mirror image of the truth.
Yes.
And your,
this is what you're fighting constantly on your show.
Well it actually gives you a headache.
Like I have a bunch of kids and they lie because everybody lies and you
especially lied to the people you love because you care about their opinion.
Most.
So kids lie to their parents like it's a feature of it,
but a child's lie is very recognizable because it's always three shades off from
the literal truth.
So it's like you ate 10 Oreos.
No,
I just had three,
but no one is contesting that you wait the Oreos.
Right.
What they're doing is what all authoritarian regimes do in Orwell,
being the great genius in English ever got right to the heart of it.
He's like,
you know,
if I were dealing with a a powerful leftist,
I would say you went through and it'd be like,
no,
actually you did.
You hit the Oreos and I'm going to punish.
It's like,
what?
No,
that's the it.
It's actually much more effective and manipulative not to grade the truth and
distort the truth,
but to tell the opposite of the truth because it throws the other person
completely off of the bat.
That's been why they hate all of the suppose minorities who who walk away leave.
That's,
there's nothing they hate more than a gay person that leaves a black person.
Really an Asian person that leaves.
Yeah.
I can't imagine I have,
you know,
just because of my job.
I mean I know a lot of people who dissent from the Orthodoxy within their group.
Do you know,
cause I try to have him on because I think they're brave.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I'm not involved in any of these debates.
I'm so,
but,
but like if you're a gay guy who was like,
you know what?
I'm not really on board with this.
What happens to you?
It's and I have deep sympathy for my Twitter lately.
No,
I haven't.
I would never go there because it upsets me.
I think in the end the individual has a right to make up his mind.
You can control what I do.
Okay.
Societies get to do that.
They get to control the behavior of the people who live with them.
You're not allowed to sleep in a crosswalk.
Sorry,
we don't allow it.
Fine.
What you can't do is control what I think that's not allowed.
That crosses the line from order to totalitarianism and all of a sudden for the
first time,
my life,
that's what they are.
Not simply attempting but demanding.
Yes.
All right,
so then that's a perfect segue to the technological part of this.
Uh,
cause I think the last time I was on your show,
this is what we discussed,
just what's going on with Google,
what's going on with the algorithms,
are people be in shadow,
banned,
etc. Etc.
I think there's plenty of evidence that yes,
this is all real.
What is your solution to this?
I know,
I suspect you don't want the government coming in and fixing this or is this a
unique case now?
Well,
it's,
I think it's a,
it's an,
I hate to use the term existential threat because it's so and overused,
but actually it is an existential threat to the ability of the US government to
run the country to administer the democracy.
Um,
yeah,
look Google,
there are 20,000 engineers,
engineers making between two and $400,000 working right now just on Google
search.
Just on that one feature of Google 20,000 this is the most technologically
advanced and powerful organization in the history of the world.
It's technology and capabilities so far outstrip those are the Pentagon for
example,
or the Chinese military or the Russian,
the Russians or any other group.
This is the most powerful technological entity in the world,
which has a chokehold on all human information in English.
So that is all sort of all you need to know.
I don't care if Jesus is in charge of the country.
That's too much power for any entity to have.
And it's a,
it's a threat to the nation state actually,
and it's a threat to all of us.
So yeah,
I think whatever it takes is what we need to do.
Like now.
Yeah.
Is that a tough pill for a conservative to say?
They don't know.
Are you kidding?
Well,
first of all,
I would say not to go to motive.
I hate when people do that,
but in fact a lot of them are just flat out bought off by Google.
Right?
Google literally funds the antitrust think tank in Washington.
[inaudible]
no,
but look,
but it's so asymmetrical,
like all these debates are because with liberals who are only about power,
you just make the pitch like,
look,
we'll fund you.
We're on your side.
You know that we're part of the coalition of the ascendant.
So just like no problem with conservatives,
all the who are sort of like dog,
like in there.
Ooh.
Murcott you know what I mean?
It's like,
what are you against markets you want government control you for regulation.
I'm ran and ran and ran.
That concern was like,
oh my gosh.
Kryptonite.
I'm sorry.
You're right.
You're totally right,
Mr Google.
It's actually,
and so I feel like I'm the only person who like,
yeah,
of course I'm conservative.
Of course I'm not for regulation.
Of course,
I believe in markets,
but this isn't a free market.
This is your freedom.
This is your version of capitalism.
This is what you've been promising all these years when like two guys who run a
company,
it's not even American whose values are not aligned with the interest of my
country is in charge of the country.
No,
I'm not for that.
I gotta say this man,
I did not think that I was going to bring you in here and that I'd have Tucker
Carlson agreeing with my friend Eric Weinstein about this.
But that you're basically laying out the same case,
easily laid too big
and,
and sometimes I think,
well maybe I'm going crazy.
Maybe I'm thinking about this too much and I'm becoming like the Wacko who's
like,
you don't understand the threat actually the deeply,
and I know people who work there and I've actually spent a lot of time on it
cause I'm,
cause I know,
I don't think I'm overstating it.
And by the way,
I'm not temperamentally an extremist.
I'm always,
I'm from southern California,
you know,
I'm a kind of semi observant Episcopalian.
I'm not like no more,
you know,
the end is no,
I am.
That's not the way I am.
But on this topic,
I think I'm becoming that because I think the facts warranted.
What do you make it,
the whole shift sort of of what's happening with news and technology at the
moment that,
it's funny,
I said this to you in the green room,
but when I was doing a shoulder Peters and last week I said,
Oh,
you know,
Tucker Carlson's on my show next week.
The audience went wild,
like went crazy.
And I was like,
oh,
that's interesting because I hear from so many of these young people that they
don't get their new now,
uh,
from cable news anymore.
I think you and Gutfeld are a little bit of a like a bridge sort of between
mainstream and,
and the Internet thing.
Um,
but that,
that CNN has sort of become a joke that,
that just saying these things about cable news,
that's already the punchline.
And I spent many years at CNN hosting a show there and had a lot of,
have,
have friends there.
I mean the landscape changes technology,
you know,
destroys and then creates,
it's a very familiar cycle.
I think cable news has remained relevant much longer than a lot of us who work
in a thought it would,
but that of course will change because technically,
once again,
technology changes everything.
What's ominous is the next thing.
I'm completely for digital media.
I own part of a digital media company,
but we've sort of wound up exactly and not in the opposite place.
We expected to wind up.
I mean the promise was that this was going to diversify,
you know,
the media and decentralize power over information and of course the opposite,
Google controls everything.
So without youtube,
I mean where are you with at Youtube?
So we're actually finding ourselves more dependent upon a smaller group of
people who hate free speech and hate our values.
That's a very precarious place to be.
Somebody needs to introduce competition into this space.
Like yesterday,
like right now it's the most important thing.
Otherwise we're going to find ourselves like at the mercy of these commissar.
It's like,
is that where you want to be?
It's the opposite of where you want to be.
If only there were some influential billionaires.
I know that might be listening to this show.
We're not going to name names,
but whenever,
two or more people who thought this through for 10 minutes get together,
they mentioned one name and they're like,
why is he coming me to save us?
Well now you said it's a he,
but let's not get lost in gender pronouns.